ah
nice our bushwhack has commenced
we want to make our camp more like home
so we're going foraging for wood and
supplies to build some furniture but our
camp here is situated on protected land
so we need to hike to a spot Upstream
where the government allows you to cut
down dead trees and and live branches
and basically Source the wood that we're
going to need and we're bringing the
canoe on this bushwhack so we'll have a
way to bring all this wood back to our
campsite
to know reverse to your left turn the
back I'm just going to go straight here
in the canoe is definitely an awkward
and uncomfortable thing to do with all
the weight on your shoulders but he also
can put it down at any moment I'm
carrying both children each weigh 30
pounds so
basically wearing a 60 pound weighted
vest and I cannot take it off and put it
down for a moment but I think I have the
cuter job
I think this is our best bet ah
there we go
that's wonderful good job oh yeah
I'm just noticing how happy Wesley is
and how much eye contact he's been
making with me and um eye contact is
something that he's not always been so
good at and it's a big indicator of some
progression for him so
hi there it is hi sweetheart
yeah I think this is so good for him
oh
I feel like I'm floating
look at West sitting so high in the
canoe there on his elbows come here Wes
he was so happy pretty much the entire
walk like when he wasn't sleeping it was
like super happy also just looking
around at his surroundings like looking
up at the trees that's really good it
just goes to show that it's even better
for him to be in the outdoors and in
nature than your average person yeah so
you know just that I don't know just
different surroundings or whatever it is
it seems to be working for him
it's fun to watch Hudson interact with
Wesley Hudson doesn't see Wesley any
differently than he does Jim or I
I feel like it's definitely helped
Wesley just have another person there
that kind of he can connect with even
though his little brother pulls his hair
sometimes and doesn't matter and I also
think that that Hudson is going to learn
so much more responsibility and and be
so much wiser at such a young age
because of his brother's challenges
judging by the way that the kids are
behaving and how happy they are out here
it's making me think that uh you know
maybe we get a little property in a
place like this and build a little
Wilderness home
even if there's potentially a place of
buying a remote property in there it
could be a possible place that we might
consider building an off-grid cabin and
slowly you know basically starting to
make that our home base till one day
maybe that's our permanent residence who
knows that would be amazing uh yeah
[Music]